this is a very important video for
anyone with an autoimmune disorder or
for that matter any inflammatory
disorders now of course the thing to do
if you have an autoimmune condition is
go to The Experts right so this is what
they will tell you what to do right
consume plenty of fruits and vegetables
and whole grains legumes only have
moderate amounts of alcohol limit your
sugars and sodas and also limit your
refined grains but of course the diet is
going to recommend you can have some
sugars you know juice and alcohol and
sugar and fine grains just don't have
too much and you'll be totally fine well
I'm going to let you know right now you
will never ever get better if you follow
that recommendation so let's go ahead
and dissect and talk about what's really
behind an autoimmune disorder most
autoimmune disorders where your own
cells are attacking itself creating a
lot of collateral damage with
inflammation
start in the gut but I want to talk
about the mechanism of what starts it in
the gut we have this immune barrier okay
we also have other barriers on their
skin the internal skin we have other
immune things like acids in your stomach
bile that's produced by the gallbladder
lactic acid that's produced by some of
your microbes that all prevent pathogens
from invading the body and we also have
this thing called the blood-brain
barrier which protects pathogens from
invading the brain and so the immune
system and I just have to say this is so
highly complex and so mysterious
really no one understands the complexity
of this magical defense mechanism and
how amazing it is and when you
appreciate it you're much less
susceptible to using things to try to
bypass your immune system like
antibiotics for example or anything to
stop an infection you want to let your
body learn from it and develop more
immunity but before we get into this I
want to just touch on something that's
really important
that's about the immune system since
we're on the topic of autoimmune our
immune system is developed when we're
small infants hopefully you had a
natural childbirth you weren't C-section
because that can inhibit the starting of
the immune system because of the
microbiome that's developed in a natural
birthing process and hopefully you are
breastfed too because of the probiotics
that are in the breast milk really
fortify that immune system early on you
know when we talk about a fetus growing
in a mother's womb it's not a sterile
environment they did think it was
sterile at one time but they recently
found microbes in the amniotic fluid and
some babies actually have their first
bowel movement right inside the womb and
they found microbes in there where do
they come from well they came from the
mother and so an infant's immune system
starts at Birth and if they don't have
these certain factors okay if things are
too sterile if an infant is exposed to
antibiotics or anything that can inhibit
that microbiome boy is that immune
system affected later on in life and the
recent interest that I have in this
topic relates to farming
and growing certain plants and I'm going
to be doing some very interesting
research on my farm relating to this
topic but a seed that is grown in the
soil is not just a little packet of
genetic information it is literally
Noah's Ark you have all sorts of
microbes it's growing inside that seed
and on the surface of that seed that
helps that seed be fortified in its
growing process and so they found that
if you disrupt that microbiome early on
that plant won't really grow it won't
really have that microbiome to help it
absorb nutrition well the exact same
thing happens with us with our immune
system early on we're talking about the
gut barrier okay there are these
protective things called tight junctions
that keep the cells very very tight and
secure so it forms a very very nice
barrier between the inside of your body
and the out outside of the body or
really the inside of the gut so if
there's a pathogen trying to invade the
gut these tight junctions prevent it
from doing so now the medical term for
this is intestinal permeability of
course it's the same thing as a leaky
gut right there's holes in your
intestine that allow things to pass
through that then don't get the stamp of
immune approval through immigration and
then certain things could be tagged
incorrectly and then your immune system
can go after them and then we have a war
we have inflammation and then we can
develop autoimmune diseases now there's
this um protein that regulates these
tight junctions and if this zonulin and
the type Junctions are not working
correctly the immune system is not going
to have the ability to differentiate
between self and non-self in other words
your immune system can make a mistake
and start incorrectly assigning your own
tissue being a foreign pathogen and
start developing the antibodies you know
whether it's for the thyroid the brain
anything and so this zonulent protein is
always elevated in autoimmune diseases
as well as a lot of inflammatory
conditions it is the primary regulator
of that intestinal permeability so if we
look at what foods are best for an
autoimmune disease it would be those
foods that reduce permeability and that
keep this zonulin in check and prevent
it from getting too high so what I did
is I cross referenced a lot of different
foods and other things that relate to
not only increasing or decreasing
zonulin but also affecting the
intestinal permeability
as well as directly causing autoimmune
diseases okay so the number one thing
that helps regulate zonulin is your own
microbiome okay so anything that
destroys your microbiome is going to be
very very bad for the situation anything
that supports it is going to be very
very good and again we come full circle
to these microbes right they're not us
but they live with us and they greatly
help us a very large portion of our
immune system is due to these microbes
and I really think if we look at the
difference between like 50 years ago and
now we definitely do not have the
numbers and the diversity of microbiome
in our guts and we definitely don't have
the numbers and diversity of microbiome
in this soil I think that is really at
the core of the problem so the first
food I'm going to recommend is
a probiotic food right that would be
sauerkraut kimchi
kefir
okay anything that will give you these
friendly microbes and you might even
want to take a probiotic as well because
we're trying to increase the diversity
of microbes now if we've taken the flip
side I think we should also talk about
what to avoid
well guess what
antibiotics antibiotics directly
increase leaky gut okay they increase
this zonulin and they directly relate
and can cause autoimmune diseases so at
the first sign of a sickness don't jump
to start taking that antibiotic and if
you have to okay definitely take a
probiotic at the same time it's so
important I mean the amount of
antibiotics that I have taken in my life
are just off the charts simply because I
didn't know the long-term effects did
you realize that when you take an
antibiotic there are going to be certain
microbes they're going to survive that
are going to develop a resistance to
that antibiotic that microbe that now is
resistant to that antibiotic can do
something called horizontal Gene
transfer where it shares this
information with other microbes that
were not exposed to that antibiotic to
give them the genes that help them
resist that antibiotic and in the future
so these microbes can share information
back and forth and this is part of the
survival mechanism that they have
developed and so the next time you take
the antibiotic it works less and less to
the point where it won't work at all
another food that is good potentially
for autoimmune would be anything
fermented okay fermented I'm not talking
about like fermented like beer or
alcohol I'm talking about like fermented
vegetables because fermented vegetables
are easier to digest they have microbes
they have the fiber that can actually
feed the microbes they have all sorts of
other secondary chemicals that support
keeping that intestinal line really
really tight but if you have the type of
autoimmune that involves damage to your
gut there's too much inflammation then
you might have a problem with vegetables
in general you might have to do
carnivore for a little while but if you
don't have that you might benefit from
fermented vegetables and this this also
includes vegetables okay because
personally I do very well on them I
don't apparently have that much gut
damage that it's a problem some people
don't but if you have an autoimmune
disease that's affecting the gut you
might not do well on the vegetables but
if you don't vegetables can contribute
to a good gut microbiome because they
feed the microbes from the fiber but
also the phytonutrients in these
vegetables greatly support zonulin and
one of the biggest ones that is very
well researched is sulforaphane and not
only broccoli Sprouts but in broccoli
cabbage and other cruciferous vegetables
so sulforaphane directly helps reverse
gut dysbiosis okay alteration in the
microbiome sulforaphane is a great
remedy for h pylori another microbe in
your body that is in the stomach that
can get out of control and turn
unfriendly in certain environments and
then it can create ulcers but guess what
sulforaphane can help kill H pylori and
put it back into remission sulfur pain
helps the mucous lining in your gut and
sulforaphane directly inhibits
autoimmune conditions okay especially
like lupus and even psoriasis and other
autoimmune conditions so you could
probably get the most sulforaphane in
broccoli Sprouts you can just put that
on your salad each day or you can get
sulforaphane in a supplement all right
let's go to the flip side what to avoid
okay
anything with the herbicide glyphosate
and this is in the Roundup Ready and in
GMO foods and if you look this up it's
interesting because you'll see these
mixed reviews of course the ones that
they say the glyphosate is fine are
funded by companies that have a vested
interest but if you think about it
glyphosate has a patent on it being an
antibiotic yeah because it kills
microbes certain things you'll see on
the internet will say that there is no
dangerous to glyphosate in humans
because the pathway that biochemically
it interrupts is not part of the human
body
well it is part of the microbes that
live inside of our gut that we depend on
so it definitely affects us from the
microbiome level but glyphosate is in so
many different things even in non-GMO
things including wheat and other grains
not to mention soy corn it's just all
over the place and so now I think it's
appropriate to bring up another really
bad thing for autoimmune diseases and
that would be gluten in certain grains
okay
gluten uh is a kind of a general term
for several um types of proteins that
have a very devastating effect on our GI
system now you might think just about
Celiac which is a very severe disorder
which is um you know not as common as
other disorders but then you also have
gluten intolerance gluten sensitivity
which is pretty common but what about
for those people that don't have a
problem with gluten right well check
this out gluten whether you have an
intolerance or not gluten is going to
increase zonulin in everyone so it's
going to open up those tight junctions
in people that are not sensitive to it
and the big problem with gluten is that
it's the only protein that our bodies
cannot fully digest okay so if we get
this undigested protein floating down
our GI tract and then it opens up the
hole in the gut and it goes right
through now we're going to start to have
immune reactions or at least
inflammation Nation especially if you're
consuming it on a chronic basis which
most people are and unfortunately
um lately in the last 20 years or more
gluten has really increased in wheat and
in other foods and so you can imagine
the amount of inflammation going on in
our guts without us even knowing it all
right let's talk about number four okay
the food that you should be consuming
food and this is kind of just a general
category but foods high in glutamine
okay glutamine maybe you've heard of
this maybe you haven't but glutamine is
a good thing to reduce inflammation in
your gut now glutamine is an amino acid
that is a precursor for
glutathione right which is one of the
most important antioxidants in your body
and so what foods are high in glutamine
well red cabbage and by the way cabbage
is just good for any type of
gastrointestinal problem grass-fed beef
eggs
fish these are all really high in
glooming now on the flip side additional
things you should avoid would be of
course glucose fructose both glucose and
fructose increase zonulin and increase
permeability alcohol is another one that
will just put a hole right through your
gut and of course vegetable oils another
big one like corn oil soy oil cottonseed
oil canola these vegetable oils are
highly inflammatory and they definitely
will create increased permeability and
of course trans fats are also really bad
for the intestinal lining and number
five food would be the omega-3 fats and
that's another category that includes
you know cod liver oil fish salmon
sardines
omega-3 is really good for the gut and
keeping those Junctions really really
tight as well as reducing the risk for
autoimmune now this last part is very
very important too and this is not Foods
it's just nutrients and these nutrients
that I'm going to talk about are hands
down the most important nutrients to
support the zonulin to support
autoimmune to sport the gut lining to
make it really really tight okay we have
zinc vitamin D vitamin A which is in egg
yolks beef liver butter things like that
so now you have the basic information on
what you should be consuming if you have
an autoimmune disease and since we're on
the topic of the gut another really
important video for you to watch would
be my more comprehensive video on the
digestive system and I put that up right
here check it out